play possibly a post up opportunity
hard waiting too long
would crush the defense by the walking
down durant fires
and hits with the shot clock running
down
jeff green gets it into durant
here is durant moving on tucker he turns
he shoots yes with one second remaining
one so milwaukee just
there's durant to the rim that hits the
reverse and
ends up on the floor right by the stash
it's not even fair
handles great shooting can finish
brooklyn they go hard
they go hard
[Applause]
brett stevens going to his bench now
oh it's durant on the block shot clock
3.5 remaining
and look at this effort from the weeks
[Applause]
from downtown the other night here's
durant for the birds crossover
avionics and hits
[Applause]
find his rhythm draws the foul brooklyn
up early what a play by chris middleton
snapped it off the dribble at frost
court
right into the shooting pocket of tucker
durant the drive two days ago
friday night in game three
kevin durant gets by parker that is no
va i've been in this situation before
you come in against the play
well the masked man out there bruce
brown net fans will remember back in
practice when the team was on their last
road trip in
chicago durant comes up with the block
we're looking at 34 points nine rebounds
durant had it knocked away 40 was fouled
does not get the call
let's get it back on the drive
gave her the net a steal that led to a
turnover
and durant there for the easy two
durant tucker right with him back to
brown
durant has it fights over fires a three
bang
kevin thinking y'all must have forgot
you know my work the ability to come off
and make big time
shots when it matters most mama